les nous un peu de cette rencontre
ex-ennemi ligue 1 parce que c'est lui
qui nous a proposé le rôle c'est lui qui
a eu envie de vous ça s'est passé
comment alors la petite histoire c'est
qu'il m'a vu dans un plan d'un téléfilm
où j'étais en train de rigueur d'une
bagnole et il a cherché mon téléphone il
m'a appelé il m'a dit je voudrais vous
offrir un premier rôle et j'ai cru que
c'était une connerie parce que j'étais
mais qui croyais pas au début moi non je
crois que c'était mes potes qui me font
tellement improbable oui et il est venu
à lille est là j'ai dit bas donc ça a
l'air d'être prêt et on a beaucoup bossé
et puis voilà voilà voilà
qu'est ce qui vous rend pour la petite
histoire quand vous êtes allé le
chercher à la gare un fil d'arrivée pour
le rendez vous avec votre voiture et
c'était un cette voiture pierre il avait
pensé à ce break une espèce de truc une
voiture du nord de l'europe
voilà et c'était celle qu'ils avaient
pas ce qu'ils avaient imaginé pour le
film parce que parce qu'elle a vraiment
un rôle prépondérant c'est parce que le
deuxième personnage du film cette
voiture alors cette nomination ça booste
indéniablement votre carrière comment
vous vous le vivez vous depuis votre
nomination il ya des choses qui le
téléphone sonne plus qu est ce qui se
passait c'est marrant je reçois plus de
scénario c'est étrange qu'on a et puis
aussi beaucoup de messages de gens que
je n'ai pas vu depuis 12 ans qui par
hasard on y avait un jour de l'annoncé
de ces visages des coïncidences et
trouver les bons amis comme ça comment
on aborde un rôle d'ailleurs comme
celui-là comme celui de
oui parce que c'est un rôle très dur
c'est un rôle très fort c'est que c'est
une femme qui a des tripes
il faut en avoir bavé pour ça pour être
pour être dedans entrer dans la tête
c'est rentrer dans les spots sociaux c
est ce que louise wimmer cet avis la
réponse est non non mais c'est pas c'est
une vraie force de caractère
bah je sais pas ça se vaut demander à
cyril c'est lui qui qui s'est basé sur
ce que j' étais pour réécrire ce qu'il
avait ce qu'il avait son synopsis son
scénario il à retravailler le film
justement par rapport à vous en fonction
de vos seins on a bossé un il m'a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup interviewé et
puis on a fait des essais à droite à
gauche et puis voilà il s'est adapté en
france en fonction de ça mais c'est
aussi un hommage à aux femmes qui
l'entourent et notamment sa mère
et des gens de sa famille des femmes de
sa famille sont des femmes fortes qui
ont vraiment chier dans leur vie et qui
se sont retrouvés seuls beaucoup des
femmes qui se retrouvait sans emploi
parce que le mari parti avec une plaie
cher ou un plus jeune
et voilà donc c'est un hommage à toutes
les femmes qui en chine et par extension
à toutes les personnes qui en chient
aussi dans la rue et ailleurs alors ce
qui t'as un croyait dans votre carrière
c'est que le cinéma vous n'était
pourtant pas prédestiné au départ vous
êtes plutôt dans l'univers du théâtre de
rue
on a d'ailleurs retrouvé un reportage
qui avait été tournée lors d'une de vos
participations au festival d'avignon
c'était pour le spectacle quatre
jumelles regardez c'était il ya tout
juste dix ans notre jumelle le théâtre
du cambrésis joue avec la vidéo il a
donc fallu beaucoup de réglages comme
ici au gymnase de roubaix pour donner à
la pièce un ton disons très particulier
on n'est pas payé et en plus on doit
faire la vaisselle la lessive monter
démonter faire les décors laver les
voitures et une tête ratée et mettre des
affiches
ce soir là une poignée de spectateurs
avaient choisi parmi les 700
représentations du off re quatre
jumelles
une véritable performance de 50 minutes
où l'engagement physique des acteurs
laissent des traces
corinne ça vous évoque quoi quand vous
voyez ces images et quand vous vous
imaginez le 22 février prochain aux
césar ben ça fait partie
du métier d'aller à droite à gauche de
faire de la russe s'était pas de la rue
d'ailleurs c'était de la salle et c'est
un des spectacles j'avais préféré faire
c'est avec une compagnie de la région
qui s'appelle le tec et on va sans doute
jouer ce spectacle et quatre jumelles de
copies au théâtre massenet au mois de
mai alors si le permet à bat avec grand
plaisir
est ce que c'est c'est une compagnie qui
est vraiment vraiment chouette le thé
adorez vous continuez aussi c'est parce
que c'est votre e nicolas créera une
compagnie qui s'appelle détournement
roubaix et quand je peux je me glisse
vous venez y apporter un petit détour
j'ai un petit détour notamment il est
bon de rue c'est moi c'est le hasard et
c'est de là d'où vous venez c'est là que
vous avez commencé et se trouve il a
félicité et c'est là voulait rester donc
c'est le fait d'avoir un césar aux fins
d'être nominé c'est manuel rivas qui
valent la parole c'est en tout cas ils
voient pas si ça peut mettre un focus
sur le travail que font des tas de gens
intermittents du spectacle dans la
région qui est si ça peut donner un
petit focus là dessus tant mieux je suis
bien content qu'il va en tout cas on
croise les doigts pour vous corinna pour
le 22 février on sera avec vous on vous
soutiendra et merci d'être venu avec
nous ce matin
[Musique]